regarding culture war like you were
talking about earlier i wanted to kind
of ask you something about that
i the reason i brought up daryl davis
earlier was because i think
i see that as um as a way to counter the
this
critical race side of the combat yeah
combat
do you have any ideas of how to how to
combat that
yeah i mean you need to do two things
one is that you need to call out the
ideology for what it is you need to
expose it
and you need to shut it down so that's
the kind of aggressive
uh kind of more offensive strategy but
that's not really enough right you also
need to present an alternative model and
the the reason i asked is he come from a
faith background is because the most
successful
stuff that i've seen um is is is a
different kind of
epistemological model a different kind
of theoretical model a different
personal model it's it's a
reconciliation model and that comes from
a religious background and i think
the the the distinction we were talking
about earlier between you know
the kind of martin luther king vision
and the critical race
theory black lives matter vision is is a
deep and profound division
because if you look at mlk which is uh
his work is amazing i mean he he's a
preacher right he's a christian
preacher so he comes from a really deep
spiritual background and the civil
rights movement was largely driven
in the black south by the black churches
so they're coming from a christian
perspective that we're all created
equally under god
we're all kind of brothers in this all
created in the image of god
the second thing and this is something a
lot of people don't know is that martin
luther king was a
deep student of american history and in
a lot of ways revered the founding
fathers
jefferson even a lincoln and you read
his uh
writing on this and it's it's it's
actually amazing his essays and
and and he basically says we're
collecting on the promise of america
um and and and you know and you can look
even at
lincoln lincoln saw himself as is doing
the kind of jefferson
created the inspiration but was
tragically flawed couldn't do it in his
lifetime
or even in his personal life um lincoln
saw himself as fulfilling that vision
and then king saw himself as that kind
of third step
the critical race theorists it's based
in kind of
german marxism and atheism it's a
completely different intellectual
lineage
that goes back hundreds of years they're
not compatible and i think in
in my life the you know i spent i spent
five years directing a documentary for
pbs about the poorest american cities
and
the reconciliation model and in many
ways the faith-based model
is one that works much better you know
what's really interesting is i had a
similar conversation
on one of our previous shows about the
moral frameworks that we experience the
world through
and i think whether people realize it or
not most of americans
experience the world through a christian
or judeo-christian moral framework even
if they're not religious
so uh the way i explain this i was once
i'm chilling at my house
and i notice a bunch i live in a i live
in a dead-end street it's like on
purpose
and then i see people walking down my
block knocking on every door and i'm
like i wonder what they're selling or
preaching
and then all of a sudden these two like
you know young teenage girls are
knocking on my door
and they were preaching they were they
were there to spread the good word and
they had bibles and stuff i don't know
exactly which denomination they were
they asked me if i had a minute to talk
to them about jesus christ and all that
and i told them i really respect and
appreciate what you're doing
i myself am not um you know i i'm not
one for
you know this theistic religion but i
will tell you a few words of praise i
have for your religion
notably the story of um sodom and
gomorrah
uh specifically i think i think it's
time to make more i will not destroy the
city if there is but one virtuous person
that that moral framework is the root of
the fifth amendment innocent until
proven guilty in a right to a speedy
trial
from that idea we had a really really
long time ago rooted in these values
we then created blackstone's formulation
are you familiar with blackstone's
formulation they did not it is better
that ten guilty persons escape than one
innocent sufferer great
that protecting the innocent is more
important than punishing the wicked
from that we've created a system that
has one of the best
justice systems in human in human
existence
i am not a a christian
a lot of people seem to think i'm an
atheist for some reason i don't know why
that is i'm not
either yeah no i believe in god i do but
i just don't believe in
um i grew up catholic briefly i'm not uh
i don't believe in scripture and stuff
like that but i do believe in
god it would be a much longer moral and
philosophical conversation i'd have with
someone but i'm not an atheist
i don't know if i don't think agnostic
is the right word but i was
i started to realize morality for many
people
in this country we understand these
values
like if you ask the average person who's
an atheist if they know what sin
is they will say of course in in a
religious context
but if you go to say you know china and
ask them
they're going to be like i don't know
what you mean unless they've actually
studied you know western religion they
have a completely different religious
structure
a different moral framework for how they
view the world critical race theory
the woke all that stuff doesn't exist
within the same moral framework so like
you said it's a
totally different line of thinking
compared to the rest of us
i wonder if that is the real split that
even though
i'm not religious at all it's it's
really interesting to see
you know the old liberal arguments back
in the day about religion versus
uh you know christianity saying that you
know i'd hear christians say without
without religion
then why don't you just go and commit
x-crime or whatever
and then the liberals would say like you
need religion to stop you from
committing crimes well
not realizing the only reason they feel
that way is because they were raised
on moral values that were rooted in the
bible
so the way i always explain it is we
want to keep the good and get rid of the
bad
and so when you look back at the history
i was i remember reading about the fifth
amendment
and why we have a right to a speedy
trial why why we have a right to remain
silent
why we're innocent until proven guilty
the presumption of innocence and then
you start going down the rabbit hole
then it's like well the earlier ideas of
blackstone's formulation actually
benjamin franklin said it's better than
100
guilty persons escape and then i go back
even further and they and then i read
blackstone's formulation was actually
from the bible it was the story that god
would not destroy the city if there was
but one righteous person because you
could not
hurt that innocent and and it's
interesting because then this
is in line with deontological philosophy
an immoral act against one is an immoral
act you can't commit
versus utilitarianism which i think now
we start getting to the philosophical
conversation of
critical race theorists seem to be
utilitarian
yeah kill a hundred people if it says
saves a thousand whereas the rest of us
are more
deontological you kill 100 people to
save one
good person i mean it's i think it's the
trolley problem on on steroids
yeah yeah and you know so for the for
the most of us
you know it's uh you're familiar with
the trolley problem i'd imagine for
for those that aren't familiar it's the
idea is you've got a a train coming
and there's it splits into two tracks
where there's five people in one person
and it's going to kill five people
unless you pull the lever but if you do
you'll kill that one person do you do it
and that's kind of showing you the
difference between
deontology versus utilitarianism which
is will you
act that will kill one person it could
save people
and then the utilitarian is kill the one
person save the five and it's kind of a
you know the trolley problem
there's a bunch of other really
interesting ones i really like that meme
where it's like
it's one track and there's a 100 people
and it's like you can stop the train at
any time but it would cut corporate
profits
you know anyway i digress i think that
we might be seeing that route where we
really have
utilitarians they don't care about you
they don't care about your life
they don't care about if you suffer they
care about
the collective so maximizing what they
view as good
and the scary thing is who who is
actually in control of what is good and
what is bad
you know yeah i mean it and it's i think
a lot of times we get in trouble because
people say well it's just racial
sensitivity training or well it's just
that
you know it's important to look at human
life and society through the lens of
race
these very naive and kind of very nice
sounding
very simple formulations i mean that's
true but
if you look at the actual beliefs and
the papers and the books and all the all
the studies from the critical race
theorists i mean
they're very clear in what they believe
and they basically say the system of
individual rights
the system of private property the
system of equality under the law the
system of non-discrimination
all of those things are used to justify
justify collective inequalities and
we need to basically get rid of those
things
the constitution that you're talking
about the justice system that you're
talking about
all of those complex moral questions
that we've been answering for
thousands of years and they basically
say we have the new answer
and the amazing thing is that it always
comes back
to a kind of very utilitarian very
economic formulation it's always
redistribution of wealth and property
yeah they
they can't get out of that and you read
the papers you're like okay
think it through the lines of race all
right right you know whiteness says
property all right that's kind of
strange but then
the end of it is like the only solution
is to get rid of the constitution and
redistribute
a kind of wealth along these lines but
so i think that the race theorist is
quite interesting because at the end of
the day
underneath the critical race theory is
critical theory
is marxism and a lot of people like will
beat up on you about that and say that's
not true you just think everything's
marxism but
the the dichotomy the the the kind of
dynamic that they describe is oppressor
and oppressed it used to be the
bourgeois and the proletariat
america has a large middle class we have
amazing technology we have
happy citizens for the most part very
affluent um
very progressive in the mindset of
technology and
wealth they said oh that's not going to
ever work we can never have kind of
the proletariat revolution to overthrow
the bourgeoisie
we need to re rethink about this and
then they said let's
graft identity politics onto that
marxist dichotomy of oppression
oppressed
instead of bourgeoisie and proletariat
we have black and white or black people
of color
because race is two things one it's
malleable
it's abstract you can make it into
anything that you want
and two it's extremely emotional it has
a
just raw emotional power and they're
saying we can harness that power
much more than class-based interests and
that's where we are today
you know i like asking people i don't i
i usually don't go beyond this because i
just i just like to see what their
reaction is
i have friends who are very woke and i
usually you know i have a lot of friends
from back home
and when they're preaching all the smoke
stuff i'll message him and say
i had a question um if you don't mind do
you agree with dr martin luther king
jr's dream
and they always say of course
and then i say so do you believe we
should judge people on the content of
their character not the color of their
skin
and then their mind breaks why would
they say no to that
because they just started posting a
tirade on facebook about how white is
bad
or whiteness is property and white
privilege and then
my response to that is do you agree with
dr king well of course you're supposed
to it's acceptable
so what this the reason i i i'm bringing
this up is
it's not about your ideology it's about
how people are basically saying whatever
they think is socially acceptable
however it is socially unacceptable to
say you disagree with dr king
yeah but you can't agree with him and
critical race there at the same time
it's not
possible right now they have created
this
amazing system where you actually have
two jigsaw pieces that don't fit
together
smashed together and then wrapped in
duct tape to make it work because they
simultaneously hold two ideas in their
head
and it's amazing that they can actually
be posting about how they want to judge
people
everyone on the color of their skin yeah
while agreeing with dr king they
shouldn't
do it because they're both it is both
socially unacceptable
for for you to reject either of these
ideas like you can judge people on their
genetics
you know genetics are a code that read a
certain
amount of information so if you you want
to acknowledge that information
you know what you'll find is that judge
them on that just say
it is x y z it is a one on this scale
yeah by putting it on a graph if you
want to say
this dna reads g what i don't know what
the d and i don't not much of into
molecular science but
you if you want to list their gene code
but what do you mean by judge them
by judge it you would be listing their
gene code on a piece you name judge then
well that's a form of judgment writing
something down on a piece of paper is a
form of judging
an idea it's a form of judgment you've
decided this is what it is
and you could do that about every race
and every genetic code of every human
so we're different we're all genetically
different
that's not what that's that's not what
they mean by judging someone
unfortunately
i think they take a more superficial
thing and it's like if i see a color
then i associate it with this
what do you mean like they're judging
based on the color the skin color as
opposed to just making acknowledgements
about what the genetics are yeah our
genetics are different
it's good you know variety is the soul
of the future it's it's
what we you know it makes our immune
system stronger
well that's actually offensive too to
them
you can't you can't talk about that
racist social construct
i mean there's there's interesting
points we made about the idea of it
being a social construct because we
talked about this
the other day with this leftist guy and
ideas like
if you have saint albino about albino
black person
that person still probably or may
identify as black
and many people still might look at them
and say they're black but then you can
have actual people like rachel dolezal
who are literally white but change their
hair and then people just believe
they're black so
there are you know weird social
constructs and assumptions being made
about race or whatever
but i think that actually in my opinion
disproves critical race theory
the fact that a white person and there's
many of them are currently pretending to
be black
shows that their ideas about oppression
oppression and oppressed
aren't true because they're actively
trying to be oppressed
now why would that make sense no it it
you're right but it's a bit more
complicated than that there's a more
subtle distinction to be made
um we are in a kind of social this
really bizarre
bifurcated social environment where uh
if you are in corporate if you're in
corporate if you're in academia
especially academia
if you're in a kind of high education
high status high prestige occupation
being a person of color is a tremendous
advantage you talk to any hiring manager
this is just a kind of truism it is what
it is um
but there's another distinction though
so you know kind of
people in academia you have all these
kind of white women pretending to be
latina or black to advance their
academic careers these are like kind of
like
like low-tier kind of garbage academics
but they say this is my ticket to get
that great
elizabeth warren and you see the job
listings a friend of mine is a college
professor and he said look at these job
listings and it's like
you have to acknowledge the land you
have to be anti-colonial you have to be
this and that and it's like
you know like uh to be a professor of
anything so
so there's status and and kind of
advantage there but
if you look at people in the lowest uh
economic bracket the bottom 20 percent
the bottom quintile
um it still is unfortunately there still
is a a a racial dynamic a class dynamic
especially now a class dynamic
um where that's not true so and and
unfortunately honestly the thing that it
really irks me about critical race here
the thing that to me is like the true
moral crime of critical race theory it
what it does it it enhances and
solidifies the social status of woke
elites
of any race but it's an ideology that is
deeply destructive to actual
poor people of all races it does nothing
to raise up people in the poor
communities in white youngstown ohio and
black south memphis and latino stockton
it's a bespoke elite ideology that is
self-serving
and actually destroys the very
foundations of life
for poor people in the united states
that the two-parent family
uh the the the faith community uh the
the habits of kind of work and workforce
participation
it wants to obliterate all those things
under the illusion that it's oppressive
while at the same time the elites who
preach this stuff they don't believe it
because look they're they're working
very hard they have two parent
households they're doing all the things
that they condemn in their rhetoric and
to me it's not only hypocrisy but it's
deeply destructive to people again of
all races
at the bottom thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification
bell and we are also available on all
podcast platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you